oh trop fort excuse-moi
chaude c'est dingue je te demande pardon
non je voulais dire chaude comme la
braise non c'est pas ce que je voulais
dire tu as fini oui je finis oui je suis
venu parler à ta patronne alors tu peux
y aller ok va te répondre ailleurs
d'accord mais Alizée n'est pas là
aujourd'hui c'est une super fan de Ball
et ce soir les windbreakers embarquent
enfin pour la victoire chouchou ok bon
je venais juste récupérer mes billets
pour le match je les avais oublié hier
soir les billets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous respectez vraiment l'alimentation
aux dernières nouvelles oui
alors inspectez ça
oui ça me semble parfait oh non non non
ça ne suffit pas ces trucs là ça se
mange
[Musique]
tu vois il se régale